hey guys Pete here well after the long
year wait we finally had Game of Thrones
season 7 episode 1 and this will be my
recap and review spoiler warning if you
haven't watched it yet don't watch this
video and if you're not familiar with
the way I do my recap and reviews I'm
going to do a scene-by-scene
if you don't want to watch that there
will be a timestamp link right in the
beginning of the description so you can
skip right over to the discussion at the
end let's get right into it we start off
in free country down at the twins and I
think this kind of is a cold open so it
was before the actual opening credits
and I think that it was almost like an
exclamation point on the end of season 6
we saw that she took Walters face it
wasn't a very big surprise since we knew
Walter was dead at the end of the last
season and here he was standing and
talking and it was it was fine I mean I
think we all kind of expected this what
happened and it was put together nicely
I mean she killed off all the male
phrase as far as we know had them drink
poison and I kind of liked how she
turned in the conversation you know to
leave one multiple live and the Sheep
are never safe after talking about the
red wedding and what a bunch of clowns
they were basically and at the end she
leaves his young wife with the words if
anyone asks you what happened here tell
them the North remembers tell them that
winter came for house prey after the
opening credits we see a cold wind
blowing and it looks brutally cold I
might add and we see the White Walkers
marching with a very large army of
whites we see they have giants in their
ranks there it seems odd to me like I
don't think that they would have not
burned 1-1 but this could have been one
one I guess he was shot in the eye and
it looked like this guy was missing an
eye but I would be under the impression
that knowing what John knows he wouldn't
never just left one one there to turn
into a white the interesting part of
this was we found a brand was watching
them and at first I was kind of confused
and I well I guess I still have a little
bit confused but I guess he must have
been skin changing a raven like the way
the scene looked it almost gave you the
idea
he just closed his eyes and see whatever
he wants to see but I really don't think
that's the case like I hope it's not the
case in a lot of ways see I think that
there was probably a raven flying there
and we saw it through that perspective
but he comes back as he is arrived at
the wall mirrors taken him to the gate
at the wall and we see that it's opening
up we saw this in the trailer so we knew
it was going to happen but it's still
pretty awesome to behold dollar said was
there he welcomes him Mira tells him who
they are
obviously he's not you know they don't
carry IDs and he has every reason to be
suspicious but Brin lays down that he
knows that he was at the fist of the
first men that he was at hardhome
and that he seen the army of the dead
that he's seen the night king and this
pretty much convinces him I mean bran
says that they're coming they're coming
for all of us
then we travel over to the Great Hall in
Winterfell and we see this we've seen
lots of images of this in the
promotional material so we finally see
what's going on there John's talking
about dragonglass that they need to
collect a bunch of it they need to make
weapons they need to arm everyone
including the women Lyanna Mormont gets
a chance to put her foot down right off
the bat and so she doesn't need
permission to defend them north even
though she is a girl and she's small so
she has not changed that's a good thing
and we find out that the free folk are a
part of this plan the wildlings will be
manning the castles east wall
eastwatch-by-the-sea is the closest
castle to where they last saw the night
king which was at hardhome so tormund
oaks that they are the Nights Watch now
and in a way they kind of are because I
really aren't many of them left at
Castle black so everybody seems okay
with that I'm okay with it talk about
the last hearth and they talked about
karhold
these were the two northern castles that
were occupied by the umbers and
Karstarks who betrayed the Starks and
went on the side of ramsay in the Battle
of bastards if you're not remembering
Lord Royce says that they should be
destroyed Sansa says they should be
reoccupied
with people who were loyal to John and
John starts off this season leaving
himself open just as he did when he was
the commander of the Nights Watch he
makes it very easy to go against him he
does things that look weak and folks are
pretty rightly pointed out that those
families committed treason and that they
should just lose their castles as a
result I wondered how this was all going
to play out you know what I mean because
they've definitely been trying to hype
this tension between the two so I guess
this is kind of good I mean I kind of
like how this is I mean she has a good
point he has a good point that he can't
be questioned in front of all the other
men so yeah at the end he picks the kids
from those families Ned umber and Alice
Karstark he has them bend the knee
pledge fealty and you know this is all
in the backdrop of that north needs to
band together speech that we saw in
pieces in the trailers but the sequence
of faces here is kind of what I mean
there's real foreshadowing in this right
you see John is pleased you see Sansa is
sour and then you see Littlefinger over
on the side and he's pleased that Sansa
is sour so yeah they're doing that in a
pretty heavy-handed way so we pretty
much can gather that those those things
are going to be important later after
they leave the you know when they're
walking around Winterfell they have a
heart-to-heart Sansa is reasonable John
is reasonable it is tenuous a little bit
but they talk about Joffrey a little bit
about how no one he like didn't let
anyone question his authority and so on
and so forth
Sansa says that John is the farthest
thing from Joffrey that she knows and
she also mentions the fact that her
father and Robb lost their heads so that
John needs to be smarter than they were
so again it's all pretty plausible her
arguments are good and he is frustrating
in that way of like always wanting to
make decisions in a way that you know
he's kind of like Ned in that way I
guess you could say but anyways we get
the Bravin from Cersei she says in no
uncertain terms that he has to bend the
knee or he will suffer the fate that all
traitors do
they continue to talk his concern is
with the night king and the army up
north that will be descending on
Westeros now that winters here in his
opinion I think it's a good opinion to
have and sanso points out that hey the
walls there the walls been working
there's nothing between us and Cersei so
he points out that it almost sounds like
that you admire her and she mentions
that she learned a great deal from there
we go down to King's Landing and we see
thirsty and she has a boss not I mean I
don't care what anybody says about
anything
this map is awesome anyways Jaime comes
in she talks about this is theirs now
it's just for the taking
she notices he's not on board and happy
so she asks if he's mad and then she
says are you afraid of me and I thought
it was pretty pretty good exchange there
because he quips back that should I be
she fills them in on everything what's
going on including the fact that
Daenerys has made Tyrion her hand and
that they are sailing across the Narrow
Sea she says our brother the one you
love the one you set free the one that
killed our Father and our firstborn son
Tyrion is now giving camp counsel to
their enemy Daenerys which is definitely
a concern right so she says that they
have in our motto which they do it was
handed over to them from the Greyjoy's
and all the other boats that they hold
from marine there she asked where it's
going to land and Jamie guesses
correctly and saying that it would be
Dragonstone so she points out those are
her enemies to the east then she walks
south and she says that alaria sand and
her children are their enemies down
there over in the West
olena Tyrell which should be her enemy
so she killed the rest of her family
basically and in the north we have Ned
Stark's bastard with Sansa by his side
so so they're clearly in a tough spot
here and Jamie as a military commander
recognizes this they talk about what
they need they need food they can't have
an army if they can't feed them he kind
of points out the logistical things that
she
not have noticed and she says she knows
that this is a war for survival whoever
loses dies and whoever wins could start
a dynasty that could last a thousand
years
he points out a very obvious thing that
who would the dynasty before I mean
their children are all dead so what is
it that they really have and again then
we have tensions but there both sides
are pretty reasonable in their arguments
so she sort of rolls back to them it's
just for us but I don't know about you
guys I sort of had a feeling that she
has something else in mind and we can't
ever forget about Thirsty's motivations
she makes some really good points about
why they need to take out Tyrion but the
show is I think true to the books in her
motivations and Cersei is obsessed with
Maggie the frogs prophecy so I think
really her her biggest goal was to kill
Tyrion and it always has been in some
way of course she likes being the queen
all that stuff too but we need to pay
attention to where she goes and the kind
of decisions she makes based on that
information I think so he points out
what happened to the phrase that news
has traveled there by this point says
they need allies and she says you think
I listened to father for 40 years and
didn't hear anything from there we see
that the iron fleet is coming to King's
Landing and the sirens is badass
I mean it's described in a pretty good
way in the books but this thing is like
a floating fortress that he has on the
TV show so that's pretty awesome he has
the new iron flick fleet with him Jaime
goes on a pretty good rant about the
Greyjoy's I won't retell the whole thing
that I really enjoyed that basically
they're good at nothing they can't do
anything so they have to go out and take
things from people who can all that
stuff and he said why would you want
them on her side and long story short
eventually she tells him that she wants
their ships and she offered you're on
what he wants which is a queen so they
go into the throne room to receive urine
we saw this quite a bit in the
promotional materials although they kind
of kept us in the dark about who she was
talking to but they have a pretty good
backing
for Jamie points out some problems that
he has with the Greyjoy's and with your
on himself and they talk about I mean
your on is actually pretty articulate
here and he points out that they both
have trees and his family members that
they want to kill and they're both
fighting for the other side they talk
about the Greyjoy rebellion for a period
of time and your own talks about how he
enjoyed it and when Jamie points out the
fact that hey we were killing your
people he points out that he's glad that
they did take over the Iron Islands
because that got him into exile and if
it wasn't for that he would have never
became the greatest captain of the
fourteen seas so there's really nothing
in the Iron Islands except for rocks and
bird [ __ ] and the iron fleet and he has
the iron fleet right so he also burns
Jamie when he offers himself for
marriage by saying hey I'm here with you
the ships you need and I've got two good
hands she points out that he murdered
his own brother and he quickly retorts
that you should try it
it feels wonderful and I think he
probably got on their good side there
because she does want to do just that
right so he tells her hey I know what
you need a gift and I'm gonna I'm not
going to come back to King's Landing
until I can bring you that from there
because the Citadel and we see Samwell
and is hard at work paying his dues he
is cleaning toilets he's cleaning
bedpans more correctly he's putting away
books so you could see he's having a
hard time and he keeps looking behind
these gates because he wants to get in
there and read about how to stop the
White Walkers you see him working with
the archmaester I guess we can presume
here that this is a Bros because he's
doing medical stuff and it is Jim
Broadbent so that is most likely the
case and you know it's sort of a mentor
relationship they have a really
interesting conversation say it really
wants access to that area and the point
of view of the master or the archmaester
here I should say is quite interesting
he sees that Sam wells telling the truth
that he's actually seeing the White
Walkers but he says like people always
think everything's going to come to an
end and it doesn't basically even the
long night wasn't the end
basically and he says every wonder that
scum has ended so Samwell eventually
gets the idea this guy's not going to
help him he's going to have to achieve
what he came here to achieve by other
means and then we see him steal a key
off a sleeping Meister in the infirmary
I guess it is and he goes inside the
locked cage and steal some books which
we'll talk about later we see pod and
Brienne firing he's getting better does
she still is one tough cookie
so not likely that he's going to beat
her anytime soon torment comes over any
kind of cheeses and he seems to be
laying it on heavy which some people
really like we see Sansa and
Littlefinger watching from above we
finally find out what this conversation
is about and basically it's it's what
you would think he asked her well she
says what he want he says I want you to
be happy and safe she says she is safe
and then he says how about happy what is
it that you don't have that you need and
then Brienne comes up and interrupts and
Littlefinger goes off and Brienne puts
out the question why do we need that guy
around here and she says that well we
need his men that's how we won and Santa
also points out the fact that she knows
exactly what he wants we see Arya off in
the woods on a horse she comes across
some soldiers the big ed sheeran cameo
that we heard so much about happens here
he's singing around the campfire and you
know we found out these guys are just
regular guys small town
types I guess you could say that went
off to fight they offered her some food
it's really not that important I mean we
find out that she says she is going
south she's going to King's Landing I
don't know if she'll ever actually do
that but it's sort of like a joking
around you know they they have some wine
and some food and they asked her where
she's going and she says she's going to
kill the Queen which everyone laughs at
I don't think that there was much
suspicion on their part of who she was
but I can't imagine that she'll stay
with them for very long either just for
that reason I mean some people would be
able to recognize her
and beyond because she spent quite a lot
of time there before she went to Braavos
we then catch up with the Brotherhood
without banners plus the hound
the hell is actually like a stand-up
comedian in a way in this and it was
kind of okay like he was funny you know
I mean he calls
Thoros out for his top not saying that
he's bald and a bunch of stuff like that
they come up on this abandoned house
it's cold any a place to stay
and we realized that this is the house
that Tim and arias Stadium when that guy
offered them shelter and then before
they left you know the hound knocked him
out or knocked him down and stole his
money because he said they were gonna
die anyways well it turns out they did
die and it's it's a strange it was a
long kind of exchange you know he talks
about Derek and why does the Lord like
keep bringing you back because you're
just uninteresting so he show us some
interest in this but he's also very anti
Lord of light at the same time Thoros
lights a fire tells him to come look in
the flames he doesn't want to do that
because he hates flame he says that you
know lucky him he ended up with a bunch
of fire walk worshipers but then he
eventually does look into the fire at
first he says he only sees logs burning
and then he starts rambling off and he
sees a wall of ice where the wall meets
the sea sees the dead or marching
thousands of them so he appears to have
a vision in the flames we don't see it
as viewers but unless it's some
elaborate scheme on his part that he was
saying what he saw so we see him buried
the dead outside he felt bad because it
was his fault like I said earlier and
you know this is kind of an interesting
call back to the books here where he
would he was the gravedigger he still is
the gravedigger as far as we know so I
think that's a little nod there but yeah
I mean I guess what we take away from
the scene overall is that the Hound is
with the Brotherhood without banners and
he may be borderline religious he may be
following the law before this is all
said and done so we find out that one of
the books that Sam took was the legends
of the long night which Gilly has we see
Gillian may be Sam which is
nice he's completely worn out from his
daily duties but still trying to read up
at night they flip through the book and
he realizes that there is a ton of
dragonglass underneath Dragonstone he
calls it a mountain of it as in fact and
then he decides that he needs to tell
John this so I'm guessing that he will
send this information in a note with a
raven and that will probably get the
wheels turning in John's head that he
needs to go there we see our old friend
Jorah we saw this in the first trailer
and I thought that was Jorah and it is
the case he is getting worse his
greyscale looks pretty bad now it stayed
the same for quite a while but it's
definitely pretty bad at this point I'm
not sure if the show is following the
same thing but you know generally
speaking they don't cure greyscale they
just sort of it's sort of like a leper
community where he's at if it's the same
as what I've read before you know that
but they just keep them together and
feed them and whatever but nothing ever
comes of it he asked about Danny and
that turns out to be the transition into
her arrival at Dragonstone so we see her
come in Dragonstone looks amazing the
dragons seem to like it I mean it's
pretty with the music playing in the
background everything I mean even though
I knew everyone knew this was going to
happen and we saw pretty much most of
these scenes in the promotional material
it was still pretty awesome and they did
kind of hide those giant heads of the
Dragons at the gates you know we never
saw any of that stuff whenever Stannis
was in Dragonstone so it was still
pretty impressive we see her pull
Stannis's banner down we see her check
out the throne room we see her find the
math table and then we realized that
there have been no words spoken up until
she says shall we begin and the episode
ends right there so alright if you skip
the scene-by-scene welcome to the video
someone jump into the discussion I think
if it's a good episode overall I think
we knew most of what was going to happen
but there were a few surprises which is
good we knew what was going to happen
because they promoted the hell out of
these scenes and that's good we got a
lot of that
way I mean we knew the nurse was going
to arrive but it was still an amazing
scene or sequence of scenes I should say
and like I mentioned in the scene by
seeing the music and the approach and
her walking through it was pulled off
really well no big surprises that you
know all her buddies are with her there
except the Greyjoy's were noticeably
absent so we can imagine that they're
off somewhere else doing something else
and it was impressive I mean Dragonstone
looks amazing they really emphasized all
the Targaryen stuff there now that
Stannis is gone and they you know they
opened up a whole lot more the throne
room was awesome we have seen that
earlier but still pretty good all the
way around the John stuff in the north
is pretty predictable he's going to do
things the way he thinks they should be
done and his real concern is for the war
that's coming and Littlefinger is pretty
predictable as well he sees an opening
and he's going to exploit it for his own
games that's what he's always done I
think Sansa is showing some maturity
like she was definitely frustrated with
John but I think everyone probably was
and I think she's keep you know I think
overall she's just playing her cards
close to her chest her allegiance is
with her family and that's going to play
out like it's going to play out the
comedy was kind of good like it was a
serious episode but there were
definitely some funny parts most of them
came from the Hound and then there was
also some sad moments I mean he realized
that if he caused the death of those
people and he tried to do the right
thing which was to give them a proper
burial at the end in the snow and in the
cold what I'm most excited about even
though I knew it was going to happen is
the brand-- stuff I mean bran is full-on
watching the army of the dead from a
distance and he's just gone through the
wall so that's just spectacular I mean
waiting for that I've been waiting for
that forever and it's great to see his
him develop to the point where he is
coming full circle and is ready to come
and be a useful part of the war for the
dawn dollar said is always good to see
him
interesting to see what happens there in
the next episode from the trailers we
know he's headed to Winterfell but maybe
he'll be there for a bit first the
King's Landing stuff was good as well
can see that sirs he's been busy
plotting and scheming and even though
Jamie's not totally on board there's no
way he's not going to step up and
command this army and fight for his
family I thought it was interesting that
Cersei turned your on down whenever he
talked about marriage
I didn't really anticipate that that
would happen but it doesn't make sense I
didn't really anticipate that your own
would show up here first without any
gifts and I would say that urine is kind
of completely different than what the
book urine is like but I think it's
workable in this context like I'm one of
those people I love the books
obviously the books are a thousand times
better but I don't really see the point
in beating up the show for not being as
good as the books like I'm a fan of both
I look at them as two different things
so why beat up the show for doing what
it's good at your on as a character I
really love but my anticipation is not
that he's going to be like he is in the
books I mean they just cut too much in
the mouth for that to even be possible
and is the same thing with Samwell like
what I've been waiting for the most in
the books is to find out what goes on at
the Citadel with Samwell & Marwyn the
mage and all that stuff and it's really
clear that we're not going anywhere near
any of that stuff after this episode but
you know it's moving fast you know the
day I read something on the way home
because I was stuck in the rain and they
were saying well it wasn't so fast-paced
but the stories are moving at a fast
pace like Sam could leave the Citadel in
a couple days now that he has those
books so I think it is actually moving
fast and so far it's working and
hopefully that'll be the case going
forward like I said the Arya stuff
wasn't a big surprise but I'm sure that
fans will really hit dig that that she
did that and then it's interesting that
she said she's going to King's Landing
because I don't think that'll be her
ultimate goal but we'll have to wait and
see so there's a lot to think about
who's going to be next on her kill list
is the Hound really going to find God or
the Lord of Light or whatever you want
to call him
what's thirsty
plans on feeding this army what's going
to happen going forward there then we
know a lot of the stuff from spoilers
but I'm not going to do that here I'm
just going to talk about this episode so
I'm planning on doing a couple more I'll
do a trailer breakdown and then I'll do
some additional videos so let me know
what you want to see if you have
questions leave them there maybe I'll do
a Q&A later this week we'll have to see
how things go please subscribe to my
channel and like this video and if you'd
like it
I'll be doing this all season I did a
bunch of Game of Thrones last year you
should check out if you haven't seen
them yet and follow me on my social
media there's links in the description
on my channel that's the easiest way to
interact with me especially on Twitter
so let's start out with some hype about
this episode and see where things go
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon